Okay.
We've just learned that at least part of the
reason potentially that the Ecuadorian embassy
kicked wikileaks founder Julian Assange out
of their embassy in London, was that they
confirmed that he was indeed connected to
Russian intelligence, which by the way, should
not come as a surprise to us.
We actually suspected that for a long time
and it was confirmed by the Mueller report.
You might or might not remember, so let's
reset.
You may recall that Julian Assange spent years
holed up in the Ecuadorian embassy in London
to avoid arrest and extradition.
Eventually we learned that the Ecuadorian
embassy wasn't particularly thrilled with
Assad continuing to be there.
There were ideas that his hygiene and something
about his cats or something was at least part
of the reason, but ultimately they told them
that it's time for him to go, but we've now
learned that they were at least aware of another
factor on the basis of an investigation that
the Ecuadorian embassy conducted a thanks
to a Spanish investigation firm, which is
something that Robert Mueller also told us,
and that is that Julian Assange is tied to
Russian intelligence.
Now, the Mueller report concluded this already
a wikileaks helped the Russians undermine
the United States election.
In 2016, Assad was effectively working with
a go between, uh, between, uh, wikileaks and
Russian intelligence.
And ultimately Ecuador realize the exact same
thing.
They ended up hiring a Spanish company to
investigate Julian Assange.
Their report was obtained by CNN and it includes
information about at least seven meetings
in June of 2016, which was a key moment in
everything that was going on with the Trump
campaign.
And Russian help.
Uh, there were, uh, a number of meetings in
June of 2016 that Julian Assange had with
Russians and others with ties to the Kremlin.
Five meetings with senior staffers from our
tea.
That's the Russian state television program.
And that includes receiving a USB drive from
rts, London bureau chief Nikolai Bogo chicken.
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that name
correctly.
So the biggest news here is that this surprises
anybody because all along, you know, Julian
Assange would claim all along that wikileaks
is not politically motivated in the sense
of partisanship they aren't for or against
any party or candidate.
They don't time releases of information in
order to have any particular partisan political
effect.
But over time we started to see patterns.
We started to suspect that that wasn't the
case.
A Sanches denial of a Russian connection was
really narrowly worded.
I'm going from memory, but as Sanjiv said,
something like our source is not a Russian
government actor or something like that, which
of course left open the possibility that it
was some kind of informal actor or a go-between
of some kind that could have any nationality
that was functioning as a go between, uh,
between Russian intelligence and wikileaks.
And then Robert Mueller figured out that it
actually was exactly in this way, despite
it being relatively under publicized.
You know, when the Mueller report came out,
when the bar letter was published, the narrative
that the Trumpists were pushing was no collusion,
no obstruction.
They went on a national exoneration tour,
uh, and just talking about the obstruction
collusion stuff, sort of smothered the findings
by Robert Mueller that, uh, wikileaks was,
uh, Russia connected in this entire thing.
Now, there are some people who are reacting
and saying, okay, this is just one instance
where wikileaks acted politically in cahoots
with Russia, but basically wikileaks is a
nonpartisan actor and they don't make decisions
that are meant to favor any particular people
in power, but certainly not Russia.
That is very, very wrong.
You might recall that when wikileaks got the
leaks of those infamous Panama papers, those
papers included information that exposed corruption
by Russian President Vladimir Putin.
Wikileaks refused to publish those pieces
and they publicly even said, oh, George Soros
was involved in fabricating the Putin stuff
in order to make him look bad.
So these are partisan actors.
Now you can say you agree with their partisanship
because it aligns with your worldviews, so
you're okay with it.
You still support what they are doing, but
we've got to stop pretending that this is
a nonpartisan entity that doesn't time their
releases to have particular political impact
that doesn't make decisions on the basis of
political motivations to pretend that they
are nonpartisan actors is laughable.
So don't fall for it except that there are
partisan actors and if you like what they're
doing, defend their actions, you should be
able to do that if you actually believe that
their actions are a motivated in good faith
or that you agree with their conclusions or
partisan position.
But stop saying that wikileaks is not a partisan
organization because it is and all of the
evidence that has built up over the last,
I'd say four to five years tells us very clearly
that that's the case.
If you disagree with me, I'm open to having
my mind changed.
Get in touch please.